[music]
we had another very
successful day today
from my point of view and the most important
points is the eu support program digital
europe that we put on track together
it's about 9.2 billion
euros that are invested to strengthen digital change
there are five
key areas
high-performance computers artificial
intelligence cyber security and
trust advanced digital
skills as well as the introduction and
optimal use of digital capacities
in but we are very grateful to you for
making a very important contribution with your commitment
so that we
all realize how important it is
that  we must not let up and
that the future of this continent the
future european and very much
depends on how quickly we make
this digital wandering security
matthias securities
attractive